hello everybody my name is markiplier
this is a game about space space it's so
beautiful
the elegance story of why
but computer can't handle the rendering
all this out
so cold
there are billions and billions of stars
of the there are billions and billions
of gases there's nothing I like more of
in space something obvious
if there was a program volunteers to go
in the space with like a hundred percent
chance of dying from death by space I
would be first in line if they needed
brief volunteers more stupid volunteers
I would be there so fast
but could irrigate and all the rendering
Oh
so cool
I would celebrate so pretty there are
billions and billions of stars of look
there are billions and billions of gases
there's nothing I like more of in speeds
so grow something up here
all of every tiny speck it's probably a
star it's so big every speck is so big I
would love every struggle the terrible
experience that it may or may not be
with certain gas on the horizon just for
a chance to go this pace
my computer can't handle the rendering
Oh
so go
with celebrate there are areas and
billions of stars on Luke there are
billions and billions of gases there's
nothing I like more than speeds so let's
blow something up here
also dress
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
Oh God oh god no not tonight